شكرا لك طاهر بالفعل مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا
بكم معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه الجديده
ضمن تغطيه العربيه المستمره لتطورات
الاوضاع في السودان
[تصفيق]
والاحزاب للانتخابات دايرين انتخابات حره
اصواته الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع لا تزالوا تسمع في
العاصمه الخرطوم رغم ان شدتها بدات تقل
مصادره بالجيش السوداني رجحت استمرار
المعارك لاكثر من اسبوع فيما اكد الجيش
ورفضه للتفاوض مع قوات الدعم السريع التي
وصفها بالمتمرده
مشاهدينا ايضا مازال في متابعه اذا تطورات
المشهد في العاصمه السودانيه خاصه في محيط
المقرات الحيويه التابعه للجيش بين الحين
والاخر كما تتابعون نسمع اصوات اطلاق رصاص
وكذلك اصوات قذائف مدفعيه هي مستمره اذا
لليله الثانيه على التوالي
اذا المشاهدين الجيش السوداني اتهم قوات
الدعم السريع بقصف منشات حيويه في الخرطوم
اضافه الى استهدافها لمناطق سكنيه في
العاصمه وطالب الجيش السوداني المواطنين
بالحذر من القصف العشوائي للدعم السريع
كما اضاف الجيش السوداني ان القوات
المتبقيه من الدعم السريع تريد نشر الفوضى
والرعب وقال انها تستهدف الافراد بالقناصه
كما وصفها بالعدو
رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله
حمدوك قال ان الوضع الانساني كارثي مشيرا
الى ان المعاناه تفاقمت بسبب الاشتباكات
الحاصله بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لكن بنلتقي في ظرف
عصيب وضع
يعني اقل ما يوصف به في السودان
ان وضع كارثي
قنا اليوم بعد انا في يوم امس
ارسلت نداء
لخصت فيه
ثلاث رسائل
رساله الاولى
كانت لقياده الجيش وقياده الدعم السريع
وطالبتهم في انه يجب ان تقف هذه الحرب
ان هي حرب
المنتصر فيها خاسر
حمدوك دعى قياده الجيش والدعم السريع
لمفاوضات مباشره لمعالجه اسباب الازمه
تقدير يجب ان يعني نعمل على قيام هدنه
تسمح بخلق ممرات امنه تسمح للمواطنين
بانهم يقضوا حاجاتهم في الدواء
والعلاج
والمستلزمات المعيشه من غذاء الى اخره الى
اخره
انا اعتقد انه
ما في بديل
لغير اننا كسودانيين نقعد مع بعض في حوار
يؤدي
لحل مرضي لكل فئات الشعب السوداني
افاد مراسل العربيه نقلا عن قيادات عسكريه
قولها ان الجيش بسط سيطرته الكامله على
مطار مروي العسكري
[موسيقى]
استلمنا المطار الله اكبر ولله الحمد
عاشت القوات المسلحه السودانيه
في المقابل وقبل ذلك اعلنت قوات الدعم
السريع احكام السيطرتها هي الاخرى على
مطار مروي ايضا نحن الان الشعب السوداني
والحمد لله
لكن ما اذيناهم لانه بنفتقرهم هم ما عدوا
ونحن عارفين انهم هم مق
ارنه العمل
اء بردو بالسلطه وانكم تجون في السلطه في
الشعب
ونتابع من مروي معنى من هناك مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار اهلا بك معنا ما
حقيقه الموقف في مطار مروي
حسب التاكيدات العسكريه هنا في القياده
التي تشرف على هذه العمليه العسكريه هو
الان
تحت سيطره القوات المسلحه السودانيه
بالكامل كافه المداخل والمخارج للقاعده
الجويه الان توجد بها
ارتكازات تتبع للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
حسب ايضا تاكيدات القاده العسكريين الذين
تحدثوا للعربيه
قالوا بان قوات الدعم السريع اضطرت
لمغادره هذه القاعده من الجانب الشرقي كان
هناك
ربما يكون فتح في شكل تكتيك عسكري حسب
ايضا يفهم من بعض الثقه العسكريه هنا
اضطرت قوات الدعم السريع بحسب العسكريين
الى مغادره هذه القاعده العسكريه بعض
اشتباكات كنا قد لاحظناها ونقل عبر قناه
العربيه عندما لاحظنا اعمده ان تتصاعد من
داخل القاعده الجويه الان نؤكد ونقول بان
مطار مروي الدولي والقاعده الجويه الملحقه
بالمطار هي بالكامل تحت سيطره الجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه السودانيه وان
قوات الدعم السريع باتت الان خارج هذه
القاعده نعم طيب نزار اذكر انه قبل ايام
من بدايه المواجهه المسلحه بهذا الشكل في
الخرطوم وفي مناطق اخرى
فيما روي في الولايه الشماليه كان من هناك
بدا احتشاد قوات الدعم السريع
الامر الذي يدفع للتساؤل الان قوات الدعم
السريعه هل يعني
ابتعدت تماما عن مروي وعن الولايه
الشماليه يعني لا يوجد اي احتشادات لها
هناك
اكيد ولا يمكن القطع بان قوات الدعم
السريع ابتعدت بكلياتها وبعتادها
وبالياتها من خارج حدود الولايه الشماليه
حتى الذين خرجوا حسب ايضا تاكيدات بعض
العسكريين حتى الذين اضطروا للخروج من هذه
القاعده العسكريه العمليه في مدينه ملوي
اتجهوا شرقا لم يغادروا حدود الولايه
الشماليه هم الان في محيط هذه الولايه
يقولون ايضا ويحذرون المواطنين هنا حسب
العسكريين بان قوات الدعم السريعه الان
تنتشر في عدد من المناطق في الولايه
الشماليه عليهم ايضا ان يتعاملوا بحذر مع
هذه القوات هذه هي الوضعيه الان ليس من
تاكيد قضعي عن وجود هذه القوات في الولايه
ام في خارج الولايه طيب ما الذي رصته فيما
يتعلق بالوضع الان في مروي وفي الولايه
الشماليه عموما نزار
الان الاوضاع اؤكد واقول بانها هادئه
تماما داخل مدينه مروي الحياه الان بدات
تعود الى المعتاده
الجلسات المسائيه في رمضان المقاهي رويدا
رويدا بدات تعود خاصه في مدينه مروي وفي
مدينه
هي واحده من المدن الكبرى في هذه الولايه
الولايه الشماليه
الخدمات الان منسابه في المرافق التجاريه
الخدميه ونتوقع من الغد يبدا السوق على
المقاطعه الولايه الشماليه شهدت اشتباكات
كما حصل في الخرطوم ومناطق اخرى
الشماليه لم تشهد اي اشتباكات او عمليه
عسكريه عاد التي حدثت داخل مطار المطار
مروي الدولي والقاعده هذه هي هذه هو هذا
هو الذي ميز هذه العمليه العسكريه في هذه
الولايه لم تتمدد على قرار ما حدث في ام
درمان وفي الخرطوم بحري وفي العاصمه
الخرطوم فقط كانت العمليه العسكريه داخل
حدود 18 كلم مربع مساحه القاعده العسكريه
ومطار مروي الدولي
نعم طيب
مروي كم تبعد نسبيا عن عن الخرطوم عن مقر
المواجهات الرئيس في هذه المواجهه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع نزار
تبعد نحو 400 كيلو متر شمالا
وترتكز في منتصف الولايه الشماليه او في
الحدود الشماليه من الولايه الشماليه هي
في موقع استراتيجي
مروي ايضا هي تقاطع لطرق تؤدي الى العاصمه
الخرطوم تؤدي الى ولايه نهر النيل شرقا
ومنها الى ولايه البحر الاحمر شرقا حيث
الميناء الرئيس ميناء بورسودان ايضا مروي
نقطه تقاطع لطريقه القاري البري الذي يربط
الولايه الشماليه بجمهوريه مصر العربيه
ايضا بها واحد من اكبر السدود الكهرومائيه
في السودان وهو سد مروي الذي يولد الطاقه
الكهربائيه
ويضخ هذه التيارات داخل الشبكه القوميه
ليغذي بالكهرباء بقيه السودان مروي لها
خصوصيه مروي مدينه سياحيه بها اهرامات
تعود الى حقبه تاريخيه هي مدينه لها
امتيازات ولها وضع يه خاصه واستراتيجيه
نعم طيب نزار في هذه المواجهه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع هناك يعني حرب فيديوهات
وحرب تصريحات كذلك بين الطرفين ماذا عن
الفيديو الذي شاهدناه قبل قليل
وتدعي في قوات الدعم السريع بانها موجوده
في داخل مطار مروي في ارضيه المطار
حسب ما اكد لنا بعض القيادات العسكريه
بانها بالفعل وصلت الى قلب المطار
واستطاعت ان ان تخرج قوات الدعم السريع
هذا ما اكدته القيادات العسكريه حتى انها
قالت بانه يمكن لوسائل الاعلام ان تقوم
بتصوير وبالدخول قوات الدعم السريع نحن
نشاهده الان على شاشه العربيه هذا هو
الفيديو قوات الدعم السريع تقول انها هنا
موجوده داخل مطار مروي يعني هذا الفيديو
يكون هو قديم يعني بعد هذا قامت قوه الجيش
اذا بطرد قوات الدعم السريع من مطار مروي
في الولايه الشماليه
لا هي حرب بيانات وبيانات مضاده والحرب
كما ذكر بعض العسكريين تستخدم فيها كافه
الادوات التي
تعيد من يحاول ان يرسق قدامه في ارض
المعركه لذلك نتوقع كل شيء في هذه العمليه
العسكريه المستمره منذ الامس يعني في مروي
وفي الولايه الشماليه بشكل اساسي المواجهه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع كانت هنا في مطار
مروي واصلا يعني قبل بدايه المواجهه كان
هناك الاحتشاد بدا من هناك على ما اذكر
عدا ذلك نزار انت تؤكد ان الحياه بدات
تعود الى طبيعتها في الولايه الشماليه في
بالكامل عادت الى طبيعتها في مدينه مروي
في مدينه كريمه
اساسا كريمه كانت بعيده كل البعد عن هذه
الاجواء المحتقنه حاضره الولايه مدينه
دنغلا بعيده كل البعد كانت تراقب وتنظر هي
ايضا مدينه مهمه فيها القياده التنفيذيه
فيها مكتب الوالي وفيها جهاز المخابرات
اداره الشرطه مدينه وادي حلفا المطله على
الحدود مع مصر ايضا كانت بعيده كل البعد
كل ما حدث هو داخل مدينه مروي وفي مدينه
مرو ي داخل القاعده الحربيه العسكريه
الجويه شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
التحديثات مباشره من مروي مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي
اذا المشاهدين المستمرون معكم في رصد
الاوضاع الوضع في الخرطوم اذا ما يزال
متوترا
وطبعا الاشتباكات مستمره رغم ان حدتها قد
خفتت قليلا في الساعه الماضيه نحن اذا
نبقى اعيننا على محيط مقر القياده العملي
الجيش السوداني في هذه المشاهد الليليه
اذا في هذه الليله الثانيه من المواجهه
العنيفه بين قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع
هذه صور مباشره ايضا اما الان فنتابع معكم
هذه الصور التي التقطتها الاقمار الصناعيه
لشركه ماكسر والتي تظهر الدمار الذي حل في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم جراء هذه
الاشتباكات حيث تظهر الصور الدمار في
الجسور في العاصمه والمطار ايضا والاضرار
التي لحقت بمبنى القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه
اذا كما نتابع هذه الصور الاقمار الصناعيه
طبعا مشاهدينا على مدار الليله الماضيه
كنا نتابع الاشتباكات العنيفه والقصف
والقذائف واطلاق الرصاص المستمره الذي
استمر طوال الليله الفائته على مقر
القياده العامه ما ادى الى احتراق اجزاء
كبيره منه وهذه الان شاهدوا اذا صور ارضيه
المطار وتبدو عدد من الطائرات المتفحمه
هذا هو مقر القياده العامه على ما اذكر
يعني هو احد الاجزاء هو اللي تابع للقوات
البريه السودانيه يعني اشتعلت فيها
النيران جراء القذائف نشاهد اذا احد
الكباري كذلك والجسور في العاصمه الخرطوم
شاهدوا طبعا الدخان يتصاعد من الطائرات
الرابضه على ارضيه مطار الخرطوم في هذه
الصور التي التقطتها
التقطها القمر الصناعي تبع لشركه ماكسر
اذا
ويظهر طبعا بشكل جلي حجم طبعا الاضرار
التي لحقت بهذه المرافق بعد ليله عاصفه من
المواجهات بين قوات الجيش السوداني
وايضا قوات الدعم السريع
حتى مكاتب قناتي العربيه والحدث مشاهدينا
لم تسلم من القصف في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم فقد تضررت بعد وقوع قصف جوي طال
برج النيلين حيث توجد مكاتب العربيه
والحدث دون وقوع اي اصابات
مشاهدينا نتعرف الان على الوضع في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم لكن من الناحيه
الجغرافيه
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تنقسم الى ثلاث
مدن هي الخرطوم وام درمان والخرطوم بحري
هذه المدن مجتمعه تشكل الخرطوم الكبرى
بعدد سكان يتراوح ما بين 8 الى 10 ملايين
نسمه منهم مقيمون ومنهم متنقلون اليها
يوميا للعمل وكسب الرزق والنسبه الاكبر من
السكان تقطن في مدينه الخرطوم وام درمان
الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا متداخله في
المدن الثلاث دون وجود خط فاصل بين الجيش
وقوات التدخل السريعه في حال حدوث ما لا
تحمد عقباه واتساع رقعه القتال سيكون امام
قاطني الخرطوم طريق واحد للنزوح وهو
الجنوب تحديدا الى المدن الواقعه على
النيلين الابيض والازرق وفيما يتعلق بسكان
الخرطوم بحري امامهم التحرك شمالا او شرقا
للابتعاد عن مناطق القتال اخيرا سينبغي
على سكان ام درمان انه الاوضاع الامنيه
امنهم النزوح الى المدن الواقعه غرب وشمال
وجنوب ام درمان
معنا الان من الخطوبه الكاتب الصحفيه عادل
السيد احمد عادل اهلا بك معنا اين تتركز
المواجهات الان بين الجيش والدعم السريع
في العاصمه الخرطوم
اه نعم المواجهات
الان يعني ربما في منطقه
القياده وفي مناطق
يعني جنوب الخرطوم حيث بعض
الوحدات التي تتبع لدعم السريع ولكن من
خلال المعلومات تاكدنا منها ان عناصر
الدعم السريع
تحركت من اماكنها بعد ان قامت القوات
المسلحه
بالاستيلاء على كثير من هذه المواقع الشكل
المعركه يبدو يعني تتوقف اصوات الرصاص
تاره وتستانف تاره اخرى ولكن مؤكد ان هناك
مواجهات يبدو ان قوات القوات المسلحه
تتحرك في اتجاهات متعدده وفي اماكن كثيره
بين انها استطاعت ان تضع يدها على كثير من
الوحدات التابعه السيد عادل نعم في
المقابل يعني العربيه واكبت يعني هذه
المواجهات منذ بدايتها ساعه بساعه
واذكر حتى ساعات الصباح الاولى كان هناك
يعني قصف كبير على مقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم والصور التي
تبعناها قبل قليل صور اقمار الصناعيه تظهر
دمارا كبيرا في مباني القياده العامه هذا
يدفعني كي اسال عن حجم الاضرار التي لحقت
بمباني القوات المسلحه السودانيه
نحن لم يتسنى لنا حتى الان ان نصل الى تلك
الاماكن ولكن فيما يبدو خلال ملاحظات
ومشاهدات من على البعد يبدو ان
الدعم السريع يقوم بعمليات اشبه بعمليات
التخريب يعني ليست هناك عمليات بشكل منظم
وبشكل واضح خاصه وانك لا تستطيع ان تقول
ان هناك توازن قوه بين الجيش وبين الدعم
السريع الجيش السوداني وهذه المعلومات
اقولها لك بطريقه محايده وبطريقه فنيه ان
الجيش السوداني جيش عريق وجيش كبير جدا
اكيد تاسس عام 1925 وله كفاءه وله خبرات
وله وحدات وله اسلحه لا يمكن ان تغارينا
بالدعم السريع ولذلك انا اعتقد انه ليس
هناك تكافؤا في هذه المعركه خاصه وان
الجيش السوداني لو خبرات واسعه في التعامل
مع اشكال متعدده من حركات التمرد منذ عام
1955 واخرها عام
2005 وربما بعد الثوره كانوا هناك ايضا
بكل موضوعيه كذلك استاذ عادل يعني مع خبره
الجيش السوداني طبعا
وتاريخه كذلك
وعديده وعتاده كيف يفسر كذلك يعني قدره
قوات الدعم السريع على احداث كل هذه
الاضرار كل هذا الخراب يعني نشاهد
دمارا كبيرا في المطار الخرطوم في المقرات
العسكريه التابعه للجيش كيف يفسر هذا امام
الخبره والقدره الكبيره كذلك الجيش
السوداني
ليس ليس صعبا كما يقول اهلنا التخريب ساهل
يعني انت تستطيع ان تلحق الاذى باي طرف
حتى ولو قمت باسقاط حجاره انا اعتقد انه
الدعم السريع الان بما يملك من امكانيات
متواضعه امكانيات عسكريه متواضعه يستطيع
من على مسافات ان يوقع شكل من اشكال الاذى
ولكن المحك هو ليس في الاذى وانما الحق هو
في في احتلال المكان وفي الاستيلاء عليه
وهذا ما لا اعتقد ان الدعم السريع يستطيع
ان يقوم به في مواجهه الغواطه المسلحه هذا
هو المحكه
مهم في هذه يعني دعني اسالك كذلك عن هذا
القصف يعني طبعا هو يضر طبعا بمناحي
الحياه كافه وليس فقط بمقرات الجيش
السوداني بل ايضا
بالمواطنين والمدنيين السودانيين وحتى
المسؤولين قبل قليل كان وزير المعادن
السوداني تحدث واعلن مقتل اثنين من اسرته
هو ثلاثه اخرين في قصف على على منزله
حدثني كذلك ما المتوفر من معطيات عن
القصف العشوائي الذي يطال ربما مقرات او
ابنيه يعني غير تابعه للجيش كذلك
نعم الان هناك حوادث كثيره جدا
طالت بعض المنازل وبعض المباني ومن ضمنها
المبنى الذي توجد
ومكتبي انا بجوار
هاتين
ولكن بشكل عام نحن
هناك محاولات لا سيما من القوات المسلحه
بالتدقيق
وبان تكون المواجهات مركزه على المناطق
حربيه بعينها اي حرب في الدنيا واي
مواجهات في الدنيا تحدث فيها اختراقات
وتحصل فيها خروقات انا اعتقد انه المطلوب
من الطرفين ان يعني يحصرا المواجهه في
الميدان العسكري بعيدا عن السكان وبعيدا
عن المواطنين ونقسم نقشاه وهزيم مؤشرات
مزعجه ان
الضحايا بداوا يتكاسفوا والحياه بدت تتوقف
والناس الان في منازلها لا تستطيع ان تحرك
وجود الناس في منازلهم يعني وهم خائفون من
هذا الانزلاق الامني الخطير قبل قليل كذلك
الجيش كان نفى انه طلب من المواطنين اخلاء
منازلهم كذلك ما حقيقه يعني هذه
الدعوات كذلك ومن هو الذي يقوم باعلانها
وكيف يتفاعل السودانيون وسكان الخرطوم
بالتحديد مع هذه الاجواء المرعبه
انا اقول لك يعني بشكل
صريح واضح جدا
دائما في محاكات كثيره عبر التاريخ
السياسي السوداني وعبر مواجهات سابقه بين
الجيش وبين حركات مسلح اخرى دائما ما
يتحول الشعور السوداني والشعور المواطنين
الى الانحياز المسلحه هذه حقيقه ثابته
وحقيقه واضحه جدا الامر الثاني ان هذه
المواجهات في السودان والجديد فيها ان
هناك السوشيال ميديا والتي تقوم يعني
عبرها يتم بث الكثير جدا من الشائعات فنحن
لا لا نعتقد ان هناك اي نداء من القوات
المسلحه لم يصل لم يصلنا او يصل للمواطنين
اي منطقه من المناطق نداء خاصه انه قبل
قليل صرت شائعه بان المنطقه التي نسكن
فيها نحن منطقه الصحافات
جاء نداء وقد ثبت لنا ان هذا الكلام غير
ماذا كانت تقول الشائعه كانت تطلب منكم
ايضا اخلاء المنازل
سرقت شائعه قبل قليل انا بنتي الصغيره
تتواصل مع زميلاته وصديقاته في الجامعه
فقالوا لها ان هناك
هذه الشائعه على نطاق واسعه
غير صحيحه وقبل قليل اصدرات المسلحه
توضيحا وتصريحا نفد في هذه المعلومه جمله
طبعا نتمنى لكم السلامه استاذ عادل
ولاسرتكم الكريمه طبعا ولكل السودانيين
ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء معنا نحن مستمرون
في هذه التغطيه ومتابعه تطورات الوضع في
السودان نتابع هذا التقرير الان مشاهدينا
حيث يشهدوا السودان وبالاخص العاصمه
الخرطوم اشتباكات مسلحه بين قوات الجيش
بقياده البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع بقياده
حميتي هذا البلد شهد سته عشره عمليه
ومحاوله انقلاب منذ استقلاله لنتابع
اعمده دخان اشتباكات مسلحه رصاص ودماء
انها سله الغذائيه التي ملئت قنابل
ومتفجرات بدل الطعام والشراب
نحو 16 انقلابا عسكريا ومحاوله انقلاب منذ
استقلاله بعثرت خيراته واهدرت مقدراته انه
السودان
نحو 46 مليون مواطن نصفهم فقراء في بلد
فيه اكثر من عشره انهار طبيعيه ومئه وخمسه
وسبعين مليون فدان من الاراضي الصالحه
للزراعه في السودان ما يزيد عن 100 مليون
راس من الماشيه اي اضعاف ما تملكه هولندا
هنا تاسع بلد منتج للذهب على مستوى العالم
وثالث بلد منتج للنفط على مستوى افريقيا
[موسيقى]
وفيما تتواصل الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تعالت الاصوات شعبيا مطالبه بوقفها
على الفور والوصول الى حلول تلبي طموح
المدنيين بسودان
هذا هو نشر الجيش السوداني مقاطع فيديو
يقول ان الفرقه الرابعه من الجيش السوداني
سيطرت على مقرات تابعه للدعم السريع
والاستحواذ على معدات واسلحه مختلفه
استلام
معسكر كرري السريع
اهرباتهم ومدرعاتهم
الفرقه الرابع
تستلم عدد 35
عربه
واحد عربه سحاب اثنين عربه حفار واحد عربه
تنكر ماء وكميه من الذخائر الله اكبر كلام
جميع مفرات الدعم السريع والمواقع
بالمقابل لنشرت قواته دعم السريع مقاطع
فيديو تظهر عناصرا من الدعم السريع قرب
مروحيه تابعه للجيش في الخرطوم بحري كما
سيطرت قوه الدعم السريعه على سلاح
المهندسين في ام درمان
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
واعود الى ضيفي من الخرطوم عادل سيد احمد
الكاتب الصحفي سيد عادل امام يعني تضارب
الروايتين بين روايه الجيش والدعم السريع
كيف تتعاملون انتم مع اختلاف الروايات
نحن
كصحفيين وكاعلاميين لنا مصادرنا ولنا
وسائلنا للتاكد من صحه المعلومات ولكن من
الواضح جدا انه هناك الكثير جدا من الحرب
النفسيه المتبادله
بالطبع الجيش السوداني تعود ان عبر تاريخه
الطويل ومن خلال معارك قديمه واشياء قديمه
ان يملك المعلومات عبر
الجيسيو الاعلاميه التابعه للجيش انا
اعتقد انه المواطن السوداني الان
يتعامل مع معلومات الجيش بمصدقية عاليه
ولكن واضح انه ايضا هناك من الجانب الاخر
حرب نفسيه كبيره جدا اتدور من خلال تقديم
معلومات
بحسابات توازن القوى من الصعب جدا ان
تستوعبها نحن الان نعتمد الكثيرين جدا من
المعلومات على الرغم من شحي المعلومات
ولكن نعتمد ايضا على التحليل
طبعا التاكد من صحه وانا اعود واشير باننا
نبقى حذرين في التعامل يعني مع كل اخبار
طبعا كما تفضلت في ظل سريرايين العديد من
الشائعات وكذلك تضارب الروايات بين الجيش
وبين روايه الدعم السريع ولكن نحرص على
عرض جميع الاراء لتبيان حقيقه الوضع على
الارض سيد عادل على هذه السيره دعني اسالك
اعلنته قوات الدعم السريع كذلك عن استسلام
مدير دائره القضاء العسكري كذلك
وبثت فيديو لهذا الموضوع كذلك
هل فعلا تعتقد اننا امام حركه انشقاقات او
حركه
استسلام ربما في صفوف اي من الطرفين في
هذه المرحله ام لا
لا اعتقد انه من جانب الجيش تحدث اي شققات
كما اسلفت لك الجيش السوداني يملك عقيده
عسكريه قديمه وراسخه وهو يستوعب الكثير
جدا من من الافراد
يعني الذين ينحدرون من اصول مختلفه من قرب
السودان ومن شمال السودان ومن ومن
مناطق اخرى مما يشير بجلاء الى ان الجيش
السوداني هو جيش قومي يقوم على عقيده
عسكريه راسخه وقديمه لذلك لا اتوقع ان
تحدث اي شكل من اشكال الشرابات ممكن يتم
اسر شخص او شخصين هذا غير مستبعد وفي ظل
الحرب ممكن ولكن انشغارات على طريقه ما
حدث في بعض الدول العربيه
هذا لم يحدث في السودان لان الجيش متماسك
وله عقيده عسكريه جدا لا تجعل بمنتسبيه
صيدا سهلا لاي طرف من الاطراف شكرا جزيلا
لكم عادل السيد احمد الكاتب الصحفي كنت
معنا من الخرطوم
ومشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه اللقطات التي
وصلتنا اذا لعضوي مجلس السياده السوداني
الفريق اول ركن ياسر العطاء اثناء تفقده
المصابين العسكريين والمدنيين في الخرطوم
اليوم
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور من المستشفى
العسكري في ام درمان حيث كما نتابع معكم
يقوم
بتفقد المصابين من العسكريين والمدنيين
اذا كما اعلن الذين اصيبوا في هذه
المواجهات العسكريه بين الجيش السوداني
بقياده طبعا عبد الفتاح البرهان وقوات
الدعم السريع بقياده محمد حمدان دقلو
المعروف بحمدتي نشاهد ياسر العطا عضو مجلس
السياده السوداني وهو يتفقد المصابين اذا
في المستشفى العسكري في اندرمان
ويبدو ان السيطره على القواعد العسكريه
الجويه هي الشغل الشاغل لدى قوات الدعم
السريع فسلاح الجو وفق عسكريين النقطه
الفاصله في المعركه بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع فمن يحكم السيطره عليها
سيحسم المعركه نتابع
معركه السماء وان كان الهدف على الارض ففي
السودان القوه هنا في القواعد الجويه قوات
الدعم السريع التي لا تمتلك قوه جويه تعلم
ان من يمتلك الاجواء يحسم المعركه فكانت
البدايه من هنا حيث القوه
اشتعلت المعركه حين اقتحمت قوات حميدتي
احدى القواعد الجويه في الخرطوم اشتبك
الطرفان استخدم الجيش ثلاث طائرات عسكريه
حتى الان خلال الاشتباك ضد قوات الدعم
السريع منذ انتشارها في قاعده مروي حيث
البدايه قاعده مرويه الجويه تقع شمال
السودان تستخدم غالبا في التدريبات
والمناورات الجويه تاتي بعدها قاعده
الخرطوم وسط العاصمه وعلى غرب الخرطوم
هنالك قاعده الابيض شمال ولايه كردفان
وايضا قاعده وادي سيدنا في منطقه ام درمان
بالاجمال هناك ثمان قواعد جويه اهمها
بالنسبه للطرفين قاعده ماروي لاحتوائها
على اكبر عدد من الطائرات واحدثها والاهم
مركز فعال للمراقبه والطائرات بدون طيار
وتليها اكبر قاعده وادي سيدنا وفيها مخاب
الطائرات وعشرات المقاتلات العسكريه غذاء
السالم العربيه
ايضا مشاهدينا نتابع هذا الخبر العاجل
طبعا كنا كان مراسلنا اكد هذه المعلومه
اذا في بدايه هذه الساعه الجيش الان يعلن
السيطره على مطار مروي العسكري مطار مروي
طبعا يقع في الولايه الشماليه في السودان
وهو يبعد حوالي 400 كيلو متر عن العاصمه
الخرطوم الجيش السوداني كذلك يعلن الان
السيطره على قياده قطاع كردوفان كذلك هي
مجموعه من المواقع اذا على ما يبدو يعلن
الجيش السوداني انه سيطر عليها وابعد قوات
الدعم السريع عنها طبعا هذا حسب بيان
للجيش السوداني نتابع معكم اذا هذه
الاخبار العاجله وهذه الاعلانات الجديده
من قبل الجيش السوداني اذا هو يؤكد اذا
سيطرته على مطار مروي في الولايه الشماليه
في السودان على بعد 400 كلم من العاصمه
الخرطوم ويعلن كذلك السيطره على ق قطاع
كردفان وفي اطار جهود التهدئه اعلنت
الخارجيه السعوديه ان وزير الخارجيه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان اجرى اتصالا هاتفيا
مع رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان كما اجرى اتصالا اخر مع
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده محمد حمدان دقلو
وزير الخارجيه السعودي ضروره التهدئه ووقف
كل اشكال التصعيد العسكري بما يحافظ على
مقدرات السودان كما شدد الامير فيصل بن
فرحان على اهميه العوده الى الاتفاق
الايطاليه الذي يضمن تحقيق الامن للسودان
في الاثناء اكدت مصادر للعربيه ان تحركات
مصريه جاريه لوقف الازمه الحاليه في
السودان وبحسب المصادر فان المبادره
المصريه تاتي بالتنسيق مع الامم المتحده
والاتحادين الافريقي والاوروبي وتتضمن سته
بنود اهمها الوصول للاتفاق المبدئيه لوقف
اطلاق النار ووقف التصعيد بشكل كامل وفق
اطار زمني محدد وسحب قوات الطرفين من
الشوارع والمنشات الهامه تحت رقابه لجنه
دوليه امميه المبادره تضمنت ايضا وضع خطه
وجداول زمنيه لتوحيد المؤسسات الامنيه
والعسكريه السودانيه بشكل كامل اضافه الى
تشكيل لجنه عسكريه من الطرفين لازاله
النقاط العالقه خلال اطار زمني محدد
للتنفيذ الدعوه لعقد اجتماع للاطراف
السودانيه في دوله محايده في حال التعثر
الاجتماع داخل البلاد
من جهته مكتب رئيس كينيا موتو من جانبه
اذا قال ان الهيئه الحكوميه الدوليه
للتنميه ايجاد الكتله الافريقيه الاقليميه
تعتزم ارسال رؤساء كينيا وجنوب السودان
وجيبوتي في اقرب وقت ممكن في مسعا
للمصالحه بين الاطراف المتصارعه ومحاوله
وقف القتال الدائري هناك واضاف مكتب
الرئيس الكيني ان استقرار السودان هو
مفتاح الاستقرار في المنطقه
كما اعلن الاتحاد الافريقي ان رئيس
مفوضيته موسى فقه محمد سيتوجه الاثنين الى
السودان للتحدث مع الطرفين بشان وقف اطلاق
النار وعبر الاتحاد عن قلقه العميق اذا
الوضع داعيا قوه الجيش والدعم السريع الى
حمايه المدنيين وفق ما جاء في بيان صدر
عقب اجتماع طارئ لمجلس الامن والسلم
التابعي للاتحاد الافريقي
معنى من الخرطوم الباحث والمحلل السياسي
محي الدين محمد استاذ محي الدين اهلا بك
معنا ما هي فرص نجاح كل هذه الوصفات
الدوليه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
اعتقد انه يعني سيقبل السودان
وصفات هذه ولكن موقف الجيش انه يتعامل مع
مجموعات متمرده وبالتالي ربما هذا الامر
اذا ما تم حسم عسكري ربما لن يكون من
المتطور يعني يتم الحديث عن مثل هذه
المبادرات خاصه انه مبادرات
وانت ذكرت النقاط السته للمبادره المصريه
تنطلق من من موقف قبل انطلاق العمليات وهو
توحيد
الجيش ودمج قوات الدعم السريع وغيره
واعتقد ان هذا الامر قد صاد اعوانه بشكل
واضح يعني يكفي ما نقراه من تصريحات ومن
حده
المعارك التي نراها خلال هزم الايام
طيب المواجهه هذه تنتهي طبعا الان تدور
معركه كسر العظم القوات المسلحه تحاول
تجريد قوات الدعم السريع من مقراتها
وتدمير اكبر عدد من السيارات الدفعه
الرباعي التي تعتمد عليها
تقليل وجوده في الولايات السودان المختلفه
من خلال الاستلام مقرات للدعم السريع في
مناطق مختلفه
تقليل قدرته على تحقيق نجاحات
ميدانيه في في المواقع وبالتالي انا اعتقد
ان الاستراتيجيه التي يعمل عليها الجيش
تنطلق من فكره تحديم دور القوات الدعم
السريع وبالتالي عمليه التفاوض او التسويه
سياسيه لاحقه تكون وفق شروط القوات
المسلحه هذا ما نراه من وتيره التعامل
الميداني ومن التصريحات التي يقوم بها
قياده
الروسي اكد هذا الامر ان الجيش اعلن انه
لن يقبل
بهدنه مع مجموعه الدعم السريعه المتمرده
طيب استاذ محي الدين بالحديث عن التصريحات
الطرفين الجيش وكذلك
الدعم السريع بالامس كان الحديث مع دلاع
المواجهه على انه المعركه ستحسم مع الفجر
يعني مع صباح هذا اليوم لكن هذا لم يحدث
واليوم الحديث على انه المواجهه ستستمر
لاسبوع هل تعتقد اننا ان هذه المعركه تبقى
في اطار ايام فقط ام نحن امام معركه طويله
الاجل
بالنسبه للخطوبه اعتقد انها ايام لانه
الاستراتيجيه التي يعمل بها الجيش
محكمه وتشير لانه يعرف ماذا يفعل هو يريد
تحييد المعسكرات الكبيره واخراج قوات
الدعم والمعكراتها وهذا قد حدث في عدد
المعسكرات هي نطاق الخرطوم يعني تم
استهداف معسكر صالحه وتم استلام معسكر
كرري
وجري وصعوبه والرياض وغيره من المعسكرات
الكبيره التي يوجد فيها
التشغيل والانداد والنقاط الارتكاز لقوات
الدعم اخراجها من هذه النقاط واحده من
يعمل عليها الجيش بشكل واضح النقطه
الثانيه هي
عزل قوات الدعم السريع في انحاء العاصمه
الثلاث بحيث تكون العمليه محصوره في كل
جزء من اجزاء العاصمه المثلثه وتدور فيها
يعني تحديد المسارات يعني حتى الان
العمليات تدور في حوالي ثلاثه كيلو مترات
يعني من مقر القياده العامه والقصر
الجمهوري الى جنوب الخرطوم واذا تحدثنا عن
الخرطوم وكذلك تدور في في مثل هذا
المساحه يعني وبالتالي يستخدم الجيش اسلحه
ردع استراتيجي تجاه المقرات والمعسكرات
لتدمير البنيات التحليه التي يعتمد عليها
يعني حتى نكون متوازنين كذلك هذا
السيناريو التي الذي تتحدث عليه هو
سيناريو ان يقوم الجيش
بدحر قوات الدعم السريع لكن من باب
التوازن كذلك ماذا لو كان هناك سيناريو
اخر ماذا لو
تقدمت قوات الدعم السريع ام ترى هذا
مستبعده
طبعا هي تحاول تحاول منذ يومين ان تحدث
يعني نصرا معنويا بالدخول للقياده العامه
للقصر الجمهوري لكن انا يعني احاول ان
نعطي الصوره يعني
وارجحك الى
المعطيات المتوفره على الارض يعني الجيش
الان يدير معركته من داخل القياده العامه
تشوين وامداد خلفه ويتعامل
في في صد الموجات الهجوم بشكل يعني
احترافي
يتخلص من عدد من القوات ومن الاسلحه التي
تستخدم القوات الدعم السريع ستلجا بالقطف
العشوائيه كما راينا وتدمر بعض المنشات
وتصيب بعض المواقع وبالتالي الاستراتيجيه
التي يستخدمها اعتقد انها لم تمكن القوات
الدعم السريع من تحقيق مصر حاكم بمعنى
انها تستلم موقع وتستقر فيه يعني كمثلا
القياده العامه يعني لا اتوقع ان تستطيع
القياده العامه نعم استاذ محي الدين ارجو
ان تتفضل بالبقاء معنا سنتابع ايضا المزيد
من المواد حول هذه الاوضاع في السودان
ونعود للنقاش حيث اعلن الجيش السوداني
مشاهدينا السيطره على معسكر للقوات الدعم
السريع في ضاحيه الشجره في ولايه الخرطوم
واظهر صورا لقواته في المنطقه كما نشاهد
هذا المشاهدين كما تتابعون هذه صور طبعا
نشرها الجيش السوداني
وقال ان
قوته اذا نجحت في السيطره
اذا على هذا المعسكر في ضاحيه الشجره
بالخرطوم الريال المصري يدمر العالم
المصري وتستلم 50 عربيه واثنين مدرعه قوات
المدرعات سلاح المدرعات الف تدمر قوات
العدو في الريال المصري وتستلم خمسين
عربيه لاندكروزر بكام العتاده وتسليحه
بكام التسليحه وتستلم اثنين مدرعه
اكدها مندوبه السودان بالجامعه العربيه
السفير الصادق عمر عبد الله ان قوات الدعم
السريعه هي من بادرت بالهجوم على الجيش
السوداني واضاف عبد الله خلال الاجتماع
العاجلي لمجلس الجامعه لبحث تطورات
الاوضاع بالسودان ان الجيش نفذ هجمات لدحر
الدعم السريع
ان نشير الى ان الدعم السريع هو الذي بدا
الهجوم على مقر السكن رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي في القياده العامه للجيش
في التاسعه من صباح امس
علما بانه كان هناك اجتماعا مقررا له مع
الرئيس البرهان في ذات اليوم
مما يعني يعني
الهجوم الاول كان فيه نوع من انواع الغدر
رغم الجيش السوداني بتحركات لدحر الهجوم
وطرد الدعم السريع الذي انتشر بكثافه في
المغاره والمؤسسات الحكوميه كالاذاعه
والتلفزيون
والعصر الجمهوري ومطار الخرطوم
معتمدين على عسر المباركه لكن القوات
المسلحه كانت لهم بالمرصاد وتصدت لهم
وتمكنت
من السيطره على الاوضاع وبسط وطرد
القوات المعتديه
وفي تصريحاته للعربيه قال السفير حسام زكي
الامين العام المساعد والجامعه الدول
العربيه ان الازمه السودانيه تفرض على
الجميع التدخل للحيلوله دون الوصول الى ما
لا تحمد عقباه واشار الى ان الجهود تبذل
لوقف الازمه وعدم اتساع رقعتها في البلاد
الجامعه العربيه
يعني هي كانت الاقل تدخل في الوضع في
السودان في الفتره الماضيه
وكانت تدخل بشكل منتقى ولكن
الازمه الان تفرض على الجميع ان هو
يتدخل من اجل
المحاوله التاثير على الاطراف
والحيلوله دون تصاعد هذا النزاع الى مراحل
قتل يعني تحمد عقبه
وهذا خبر عاجل الان السفاره الامريكيه في
الخرطوم تقول ان لا خطط لديها لاجلاء
المواطنين الامريكيين في الوقت الراهن
اعود الى ضيفه من الخرطوم المحلل السياسي
محي الدين محمد استاذ محي الدين في
البدايه اسالك اذا كان لديك اي تعليق على
هذا الاعلان للسفاره الامريكيه بالخرطوم
هل ينبئ بان التقدير الامريكي يشير ربما
الى ان الامور ستستقر قريبا في السودان
صحيح
عشر
استاذ المحيدين
عذرا صوتك تقطع بسبب الارسال ربما هل كررت
الفكره رجاء
وتملك معلومات وتواصل مع الاطراف المختلفه
وبالتالي
تتفهم ان الاوضاع ما تزال تحت السيطره
ولم تتدهور للمدى الذي يستدعي اجلاء
المواطنين الامريكيين في الوقت الراهن من
السودان وخاصه
[موسيقى]
امر ان تجلي الرعايه الى السفاره والسفاره
في بعيده من وسط الخرطوم في ضاحيه صوبا
بعيد عن مركز العمليات التي تدور فيه
العمليات حاليا وبالتالي اعتقد ان هذا
مؤشر على ان الاوضاع لم تمتلك الى الفوضى
الشعبي لحتى الان وهذا يعزز ما تقوله
القوات المسلحه يعني ليس هناك ما يستدعي
حتى الطلب من المواطنين
الاجلاء على الخرطومه وخروج على الخرطوم
في هذا الوقت لانه العمليات تدور
كان عمليه جراحيه رغم ان المواقع التي
تدور فيها المعارك هي قريبه من المواطنين
بشكل كبير ولكن
تحاول الاجهزه النظاميه بقدر المستطاع ان
تقلل من الكلفه في الامر ولا تريد ترويع
المواطنين بشكل كبير
شكرا جزيلا لك على الانضمامك الينا من
الخرطوم الباحث والمحلل السياسي محي الدين
محمد
مشاهدينا انها النزاع المسلح المتواصل بين
الجيش السوداني بقياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
وقوات الدعم السريع بقياده محمد حمدان
دقلو علاقه تعاون وتحالف قديمه بين
الرجلين امتدت لازيد من عقدين من الزمن
فكيف تطورت هذه العلاقه قبل ان تنقلب الى
عداوه
السودان يسقط في وحل الاقتتال بين اقوى
الرجلين عسكريين في البلاد فانقطاع حبل
الودي بين عبد الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدان
داكالو اوقع السودان في المحظور اتهامات
وتوعد وتهديد بالقتل هكذا تحول الخطاب بين
الرجلين الذين نسفا في لحظات علاقه تحالف
وعمل مشترك دامت نحو 20 عاما الرجلان عمل
سويا لاول مره سنه 2003 حين اتحدا للتصدي
لجماعات مسلحه في اقليم دارفور دجالور
الملقب بحميتي انشا حينها مجموعه صغيره
مسلحه ووضع يده في يد البرهان الذي كان
حينها منسقا لعمليات الجيش في دارفور ومنذ
ذلك الحين والرجلان يصعدان المراتب بشكل
تدريجي عاد ليتصدر المشهد سنه 2019 حين
اتحدا من جديد وهذه المره ليس الا لاسقاط
عمر البشير الذي قاتلا تحت رايته سويا قبل
سته عشر عاما
هدف مشترك جمعهما ليبرما تحالفا
استراتيجيا لكن انهاء مهام الحكومه
المدنيه وسيطره البرهان الى جانب حميتي
على الحكم خليفه سنه 2021 حمل معه اولى
شذرات الخلاف الحقيقيه فالبرهان اعاد بعد
عناصر نظام البشير الى السلطه وهو معترض
عليه حميدتي لكن نقطه التي افاضت الكاس
تمخضت عن الاتفاق الاطاري الذي حمل بين
ثناياه مقترح اصلاح نظام العسكري ودمج
قوات الدعم السريع مقترح كان مجرد قنبله
موقوته انفجرت لتنهي تحالفا استراتيجيا
وتشعل عداوه قد تحرق نيرانها البلاد وسام
الذهبي العربيه
معنا من الخرطوم مبارك اردوول القياديه في
قوى الحريه والتغيير الكتله الديمقراطيه
مرحبا بك معنا استاذ مبارك في هذه التغطيه
برايك اين تقف قوى الحريه والتغيير من هذا
الصراع بين الجيش والدعم السريع
استاذ هل تسمعني
استاذ مبارك يبدو انه لا يسمعني اذا
مره اخيره المبارك هل تسمعني من الخرطوم
طيب فقدنا الاتصال مع ضيفنا عن الحريه
وتغيير ربما نعود اليه لاحقا نتابع معكم
هذه الصور عن تطورات الاوضاع في السودان
ونعود
الله اكبر يعني احنا بنتصارع فاكلوا شراب
والتعليم والعلاج
فعلا يا سيدتي وكان الجوع لم يكفي
السودانيين فاشتعلت الحرب في عاصمه ثالث
اكبر دوله افريقيا في افريقيا مساحه
السودان والذي يعرف ايضا بانه من افقر دول
العالم خمسه مليون عدد سكان السودان ثلثهم
يواجهون الجوع فيما 65% منهم تحت خط الفقر
وفق تقرير اممي نشر منذ ثلاث سنوات كما
اعلنت الامم المتحده ومنظمه انقذ الاطفال
الدوليه ان نحو 7 ملايين لطفل سوداني
محرومون من التعليم وان اثني عشر مليون
اخرين يواجهون خطر الانقطاع عن التعليم
كذلك وسط الازمات زاد التضخم شهريا بنسبه
200% فيما تراجعت قيمه العمله السودانيه
وتضاعف ثمن الخبز 10 مرات منذ ان سيطر
الجيش على السلطه في اكتوبر 2021 وفق
التقرير الاممي ومؤخرا وتحديدا في فبراير
الماضي اعلنت الامم المتحده ان اكثر من
ثلث السكان في السودان سيحتاجون الى
مساعدات انسانيه العام الحالي بسبب زياده
النزوح والجوع معا
يا معلم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعود الينا من الخرطوم ضيفنا مبارك اردونا
القيادي في قوى الحريه والتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه سيد اردوغول هل تسمعني الان
اهلا بكم معنا استاذ مبارك اين تقف كتلتكم
من قوى الحريه والتغيير طبعا اين تقف بين
طرفي هذا الصراع المسلح الجيش والدعم
السريع
شكرا جزيلا اولا دعني اعلق على التقرير
الذي تفضلت به او الذي كان كان كان يطلع
الان هذا التقرير فيه عدم الدقه وفيه يعني
عدم المصداقيه في بعض الارقام وبعض
الاحاديث نتمنى مثل هذه التقارير يجب ان
تراجع في البدايه من مصادر الموثوقه هذا
الصدام ليس بهذا الشكل الذي يوسف هذا في
البدايه
ما الذي
رايت فيه عدم دقه يعني الامم المتحده
ارقام نعم ليس بهذا اللقاء هذا الحديث
الذي يتحدث عن الناس يعانون من الجوع وكذا
وكذا وكذا ليس بهذا الدقه هذا الحديث يجب
ان يراجعه بشكل من من من مصادر موثوقه
للمؤسسات يعني لديها من ساقيه ليس بهذا
الشكل السوداني ليس بهذا الشكل الذي يقال
اقتصادي مبارك
انا اعمل في القطاع الاقتصادي وادري ان
العمله ظلت مستقره منذ فبراير العام
الماضي وحتى في مؤثر هانك تاكل العمله
كان في ليس بهذا الشكل الذي قيل ونحن في
اخر القائمه وخرجنا من معدلات التضخ م
الاكثر تضخما في
العالم فيما يخص التجرير اتمنى ان يتم
مراجعتهم لاداره قناه العربيه هذا في
البدايه
يعني خلينا في نفس الموضوع يعني لانه نحن
اوردنا الارقام من يعني تقرير اممي من
الامم المتحده ومنظمه انقذوا الاطفال
الدوليه كذلك
وهناك ارقام معلنه نعم ولكن
انت تنفي ان يكون هناك زياده في التضخم في
السودان سيدي
نعم هذا ليس دقيق يا نعم انا ادري انا
اعمل في القطاع الاقتصادي
التضخم 2020
كان حوالي 453 ويبقى احصائيات الجهاز
المركز جامعه جامعه جامعه جامعه
هوتيل في امريكا ومؤشر يمكنك ان تراجع هذه
المؤشرات
كم هي نسبه التضخم الان في السودان
اخر تقرير صدر من ستيفانس وجينز والجهاز
المركزي في السودان
والثبات العمله ضمت ثابته في منذ منذ
فبراير 21 22 حتى حتى
الاخر في العمله يعني حوالي حوالي 25 ونحن
تحدثنا ايضا يعني وفقا طبعا للتقرير
الاممي عن تضاعف ثمن الخبز 10 مرات انت
تنفي هذه المعلومه ايضا
غير صحيح حتى
غير صحيح غير صحيح كم هو ثمن الخبز في
السودان سيدي
يعني في
حدود سعر الرغيف صحيح
ليس بعشر مرات كما يقال يعني هذا التقرير
طيب هذا التقرير اناسب اني يكون في دقتي
بس فهذا الارقام على السودان
وحديث عن الفقر والجوع وهكذا هذا محتاج
مزيد
طيب
[موسيقى]